Hervé Morin le président du Nouveau
Centre et des bâtisseurs de l'UDI et
d'invité de prépare 3 bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous pour ce deuxième
rendez-vous de la semaine de preuve par
3 dans le cadre bien sûr de la campagne
des départements comment les centristes
abordent-ils ce scrutin et bien vous
répondrez sur ce point tout à l'heure à
Guillaume d'Odin de l'Agence France
Presse notre partenaire père eternaux de
Public Sénat nous rejoindra tout à
l'heure et elle vous interrogera comme
ancien ministre de la défense sur
l'engagement de la France on le sait
contre les djihadistes au Sahel ou
d'ailleurs le dispositif va être
renforcé et également bien sûr en Irak
d'abord Hervé Morin François Hollande
était ce jeudi en Isère pour visiter
deux pépites industrielles et il
multiplie manifestement les déplacements
dans les usines ces derniers temps pour
surfer sur leur reprise il le dit même
s'il reconnaît que les fragile il a
raison de valoriser nos atouts en
rendant visite à la France qui gagne
c'est son des mots qu'on aurait entendu
dans les bouches dans la bouche d'un
ancien président de la République
c'est assez drôle quoi cette espèce de
conversion lui qui a été le candidat
contre le capital contre l'argent
bon voilà c'est un président de la
République visite des pépites
industrielles tant mieux je veux dire il
nous en faudrait plus donc
qu'on visite je crois pas au magasin si
je me souviens bien
bravo voilà
quand il dit que les
indicateurs seraient plus
qu'encourageant actuellement il cite la
croissance des investissements la
consommation bien sûr le cours de l'euro
la chute du pétrole tout ce que tout ce
que vous citez démontre clairement les
les raisons de la fin du tassement si je
puis dire la fin de la récession c'est
la parité au-delà est-ce qu'il y ait
pour quelque chose non
il cite la baisse du prix c'est la
baisse du prix du pétrole est-ce qu'il y
a pour quelque chose non c'est la
reprise de la croissance mondiale est-ce
qu'il y a pour quelque chose non donc
honnêtement il y a aucun facteur dont il
est responsable et moi je continue à
penser que dans notre pays il y a un
certain nombre de conditions pour que la
croissance puisse réellement repartir
sur des bases saines et des bases
longues et que ces conditions-là ne sont
pas réunies j'en cite quelques-unes la
première c'est le retour de la confiance
et la confiance ça passe par la
stabilité juridique et fiscale on est
dans la logorrhée fiscale matin midi et
soir et la première chose que vous
demande les chefs d'entreprise des
créateurs de richesse c'est foutez-nous
la paix la deuxième chose c'est le la
certitude qu'on va pas se faire
accaparer fiscalement par l'État en
changeant les règles tous les matins et
donc il y a un certain nombre de choses
qu'il faudrait faire moi j'en propose
une très simple d'inscrire dans la
Constitution que toute loi qui amènerait
à ce que vous soyez taxé à plus de 50%
de vos ressources annuelles et
contraires à la Constitution pour que
les gens se disent si j'investis
je suis sûr que la loi ne changera pas
parce qu'elle est désormais dans la
Constitution
le troisième vous voulez un bouclier
fiscal
juridique juridique juridique toute loi
qui amènerait à ce qu'un Français puisse
constater que cette loi l'amène à payer
plus de 50 % de ses revenus en impôts
dans l'année serait contraire à la
Constitution aussi simple que ça il y a
pas de remboursement il y a rien à
construction et comme la Constitution ne
peut pas tréviser du jour au lendemain
on est sûr que ça ne bougerait plus et
donc on permettrait de rapatrier
massivement toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont envie d'investir dans d'autres
pays parce que nous avons encore tous
les atouts pour réussir troisième
condition c'est bien sûr la
simplification du marché du travail et
du Code du travail il faut permettre aux
entreprises d'avoir plus de souplesse
pour qu'elles embauches et la quatrième
condition si j'avais en donner une elle
est plus fondamentale que cela c'est
au-delà de la question de la dépense
publique et donc de la fiscalité des
prélèvements obligatoires c'est bien
entendu toute la question de l'éducation
et de la formation
on est un pays emprunt
d'égalitarisme le premier à le dire il y
en a qui l'ont dit beaucoup mieux que
moi comme Tocqueville l'égalité c'était
valeurs de la République oui sauf que
jamais notre pays ne cultive autant
l'inégalité et pas simplement
l'inégalité de revenus les inégalités
auxquelles que les Français ne devraient
pas supporter un instant je vais en
citer une ou deux
inégalités devant la formation
si vous êtes cadre vous trouvez toutes
les formations que vous voulez si vous
êtes 4 dans une grande entreprise on
vous financera ça même si ça coûte très
cher vous êtes ouvrier vous êtes
employés vous avez besoin de vous
reconvertir vous êtes chômeurs vous
trouverez pas trois balles pour vous
financer une formation
deuxième exemple l'inégalité devant la
santé
de plus en plus croissante il y a de
plus en plus de gens qui refusent de se
soigner il y a une inégalité
territoriale les zones rurales et les
zones urbaines troisième exemple
inégalité devant l'éducation dis-moi ce
que font tes parents je te dirai quelles
études tu vas faire voilà des exemples
concrets de sujets dans lesquels nous
devrions être nous à droite et au centre
c'est à dire dire voilà il nous faut de
la liberté beaucoup de liberté pour la
création de richesse et il nous faut
aussi l'égalité parce que vous approuvez
au moins le message anti-francational de
François Hollande toujours lui il dit
qu'il veut arracher les électeurs ou FN
vous l'avez vu et il dit quand la France
réussit à bien elle n'a pas besoin
d'avoir peur alors peut-être qu'il
faisait
la France peur évoquée par Manuel Vall
sauf que la France ne réussit pas pour
les Français c'est ça le problème jamais
il y a eu autant d'inquiétude enfin tout
ça on le sait on va pas le répéter tout
le monde le dit matin midi et soir je
veux moi dire contrairement ce que
j'entends trop souvent en disant certes
le Parti socialiste à sur l’accélérateur
de la pompe à électeur du Front national
mais pas le seul responsable en tous les
gars
vous commandez quelle manière nous parce
que lorsque nous avons été au pouvoir
nous n'avons pas fait ce que nous
disions que nous allions en faire on
leur a présenté un film et on en a joué
un autre est-ce que vous êtes
responsable éventuellement parce que
vous courrez parfois vous vous
partenaires derrière les idées du Front
national
les idées du Front National et en même
temps quand les idées du Front national
rejoignent les mêmes j'ai pas pour
autant changer d'idées quand je dis que
je suis favorable la déchéance de la
nationalité française pour les
djihadistes qui ont la double
nationalité je sais que c'est aussi la
position du Front national mais c'est la
mienne je vais quand même rester sur mes
positions le Premier ministre a dit
qu'il était assuré de rester après les
élections départementales d'ailleurs
national la conférence il a beaucoup de
chance est-ce qu'il pourra vraiment
rester si le PS par exemple perd les
deux tiers de ses 60 départements il
restera vous savez pourquoi il restera
parce que le patron c'est lui c'est plus
Hollande
bah oui
la version dans le couple exécutive oui
bien sûr François Hollande est tellement
faible qu'il n'est pas en mesure de
pouvoir congélier son premier ministre
c'est aussi simple que cela
de plan B où il y a d'autres scrutins
qui arrivent les régionales
de multiples talents
mais mais il suffit de voir simplement
des indices simples celui de la
popularité il y en a un qui est à 20%
l'autre qui est à 40 il y en a un qui a
déçu qui a peiné à rentrer dans son
costume présidentiel l'autre qui
disons fait le job il fait son job de
Premier ministre avec plus de talent que
le précédent et donc en clair on a le
sentiment que c'est que c'est que c'est
François Hollande qui est soutenu par
Manuel Valls et donc on voit bien que
c'est tranquille même si le Parti
socialiste prend une déculottée
je vois pas comment ça pourrait changer
son sa trajectoire
c'est lui qui détient les clés du
pouvoir je dis que François Hollande
aujourd'hui est dans l'incapacité
politique de se séparer d'un Premier
ministre qui est beaucoup plus populaire
que lui
s'il n'y a pas de changement de
locataire à Matignon il devrait y avoir
remaniement dit-on après les élections
départementales qui vous avez Morin
aimeriez-vous avoir quitter le
gouvernement
ça change rien j'ai été ministre donc je
peux dire
plus facilement que d'autres
la question c'est est-ce que aujourd'hui
la majorité est en mesure est-ce que
François Hollande est en mesure de
d'appliquer la politique sociale
démocrate que qu'il souhaite mettre en
avant on a bien vu que non puisque quand
on bouge un tout petit peu les lignes
avec la loi Macron il faut utiliser
l'article 49-3 donc pas l'utiliser 10
fois dans l'année donc on voit bien que
et pourtant il affirme qu'il maintient
son cap il reçoit même les frondeurs
pour se rabibocher avec eux tout en leur
disant je ne changerai pas alors
heureusement que François Hollande nous
expliquait qu'il ne recevrait jamais les
parlementaires à l'Élysée encore à
renoncement de plus mais je continue à
vous dire que
voilà le il y a des il y en a qui font
voilà qui sont dans le boulot qui sont
dans leur costumes donc pourquoi les
changer puisqu'il y en a d'autres qui
sont plus transparents c'est
probablement là qui doit faire le tri
il y aura d'autres équations
le retour des vers j'ai cru comprendre
qu'au scenaille avait un homme qui ont
tellement se disait que sa place était
désormais au gouvernement en cessant
doute à Jean Vincent placé justement
vous voyez ce retour de Bonneuil et la
scission des Verts qui irait avec
je pense qu'il y aura pour le Parti
socialiste à un moment où il lui faudra
essayer de reconstruire un ensemble
politique plus large
qu'en sera-t-il je n'en sais rien prenez
le départementale après les régionales
mais il est évident que là au moment des
départementales puisque c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous m'invitez on va en
parler dans un instant on voit bien que
les coalitions dans beaucoup de
départements se font contre le Parti
socialiste
je prends mon ma région la
Haute-Normandie bientôt Normandie on a
le Parti communiste Europe Écologie Les
Verts ensemble ce qui est quand même la
carpe et le lapin quand vous avez les
partisans des centrales nucléaires
contre ceux qui veulent les fermer
Emmanuel Macron incarne la ligne
économique aujourd'hui du gouvernement
vous avez salué amimo l'avancée que
représente sa loi il y a un instant il
l'aurait il plaiderait dit-on pour
l'accélération des réformes vous
l'encouragez oui moi j'encourage de
croire le mot réforme derrière ça
qu'est-ce qu'on y met mais au-delà de ça
j'encourage le mouvement j'encourage la
lutte contre les rendre j'encourage
l'économie de marché donc vous
encourager le ministre de merci je
l'encourage aussi à être lucide et être
lucide c'est constaté que il a pas de
majorité pour ça Pierre Moscovici c'est
voulu rassurer aujourd'hui il a dit à
destination de la France qu'il était un
commissaire amical comment est-ce que
vous jugez sa dernière mise en garde et
ça demande de réforme plus en profondeur
de la France
il a oublié qu'il était mais enfin bon
ça c'est une question oui on sent il a
pas été ministre de l'Économie des
Finances c'est pas lui qui était chargé
normalement de conduire les réformes du
pays et encore combien de temps ah non
bon c'est curieux
deuxièmement
c'est pas c'est malheureusement et je le
dis sans plaisir c'est malheureusement
une chose partagée par tous les
Européens c'est que le grand pays malade
en Europe c'est malheureusement la
France est-ce que vous vous êtes inquiet
de ce nouveau délai qui a été accordé
par Bruxelles à la France pour ramener
son déficit sous les 3% des années de
plus est-ce que vous trouvez cela
problématique comme le dit la Bundes
banque aujourd'hui ceci dit c'est pas le
fait de d'être à 3%
obligatoirement en 2017 la question
la question c'est quand on fait des
déficits est-ce que c'est difficile sont
utiles
moi ça me pose aucun souci si c'est
difficile sont utiles
mais considérer que c'est difficile sont
utiles quand depuis 25 ans nous vivons
dans l'endettement sans que le pays ne
se redresse on voit bien que c'est pas
la clé alors après qu'on mette un an de
plus ou de moins c'est pas la question
la question c'est comment a-t-on enfin
un système public efficace et désolé de
le dire mais la loi dites notre la loi
sur la réforme des collectivités locales
est allé exactement à l'envers de cela
alors je dis pas que c'est la faute du
gouvernement c'est la faute au cumul des
mandats c'est la photo mode de scrutin
des parlementaire on voit bien qu'une
nouvelle fois toute tentative du
Parlement toute tentative de
simplification de rationalisation du
système local est impossible et qu'il
faudra donc le faire par référendum au
lendemain d'une présidentielle
il faut faire dans la même loi ligoté
par son propre corporatisme exactement
dans la même loi il faudra loi
référendum la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires deux des dispositifs
aussi simple que la suppression
d'organismes dont on se demande
l'utilité type le Conseil économique et
social et 3 une réforme des
collectivités locales qui nous
permettent de gagner en efficacité
publique alors on va parler des
départementales justement Guillaume
Naudin de l'ASP arrivent pour vous
interroger et puis savoir un peu plus ce
que vous vous en espérez vous au centre
on va d'abord s'interroger avec Samia de
chir sur ce que pèse votre
famille politique dans ce scrutin
c'est une élection qui choses bien pour
l'UDI au départementale la gauche par
diviser un contexte favorable mais pas
suffisamment pour permettre à l'UDI de
partir seul dans ce scrutin où l'on
n'atteint pas le second tour sans
rassembler 12,5% des inscrits alors le
parti centriste qui présente 700
candidats a choisi de s'allier à l'UMP
dans plus de 80 % des cas Hervé
Marseille est le secrétaire général
adjoint aux élections du parti dans un
certain nombre de cantons il vous a pas
échappé que le Front national pouvait
être menaçant faire des scores très
importants et si nous voulons être
présent au contour de l'élection la
moindre des choses c'est que nous soyons
rassemblés et que nous présentions
ensemble devant les électeurs donc nous
préparons ensemble la reconquête du
terrain nous l'avons fait aux élections
municipales nous le faisons pour ces
élections départementales
la victoire de la droite ne lui donnera
probablement pas de nouvelles présidence
mélangeait pas là pour ce parti qui
compte aujourd'hui 300 conseillers
généraux sortants on est dans une
élection dans un scrutin qui devrait
être favorable en nombre d'élus à la
droite donc c'est peut-être tout autant
que d'ailleurs gagner des départements
c'est gagner des conseillers
départementaux et donc élargir je dirais
son assise électorale locale ce qui est
toujours important pour un parti
politique qui a une vocation nationale
une trentaine de départements pourrait
basculer à droite mais dans certains cas
la bataille du second tour se jouera
entre la gauche et l'extrême droite dans
ces cas Ludi a choisi de faire barrage
au Front national quand il y a un
candidat autre qu'un candidat a udi
devant le Front national dans un second
tour nous appelons à voter pour lui quel
qu'il soit qu'il soit évidemment
UMP ou qui soit socialiste ou autre dans
certains départements l'UDI a choisi de
s'allier au modem un parti qui pour la
première fois ne fera aucune alliance
avec la gauche
voilà Guillaume Dodin est avec nous
bonsoir Guillaume bonsoir Michel
on avait vu lors de la partiel dans le
dos que vous aviez appelé à voter au
second tour entre entre le Fnac vous
aviez dit que à titre personnel vous
voteriez blanc et changer d'avis vous
n'avez pas changé d'avis vous répondez
déjà à la question parce que votre
partie de nombreux de nombreux second
tour risque de se produire lors des
départementales de ce type c'est à dire
un second tour FNPS votre partie est
plutôt sur une ligne d'un appel à voter
blanc d'un appel justement à voter pour
le PS en tout cas pour tout particulier
le FN vous vous préférez voter blanc
déjà un nous avons été ceux qui ont fait
qui avons permis à ce que le vote blanc
soit reconnu
bon moi qu'on en soit logique avec nous
mais au-delà de cela
qu'est-ce qu'on nous reproche
aujourd'hui ça revient à ce que disait
monsieur grossir tout à l'heure quoi ce
que nous disions ensemble la question
c'est est-ce que un jour ou l'autre les
Français finiront par se dire que
sortiront de l'idée que nous sommes
finalement dans une espèce de connivence
voilà et même qui finalement
s'engueulent sur les plateaux de
télévision mais qui s'arrange entre eux
le panier dont on parle tout le temps
voilà et moi je dis
ce sont des élections départementales
s'agit pas de la présence de la
République ça veut dire que vous
pourriez avoir une position différente
je me retrouve au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle j'espère que
ce cauchemar m'arrivera pas avec un le
Parti socialiste et le Front national là
je suis je sais où je sais pour qui je
voterai mais votre société
mais là il s'agit de quoi il s'agit
d'élection
départementale qui est deux conseillers
généraux Front national dans un
département vous croyez que ça va
bouleverser la face du monde moi j'ai
connu le Parlement l'Assemblée nationale
avec un groupe parlementaire Front
national c'était en 1986 est-ce que la
République a été menacée par la présence
du Front national certainement pas parce
que derrière tout ça il y a un moment il
faut mettre le faut que les Français se
rendent compte de ce que c'est quoi
est-ce que ça existe comment ils gèrent
qu'est-ce qu'il vote
qu'est-ce qui vote là
disait toujours voilà un maçon on voit
ce qu'il est au pied du mur bon ben moi
j'ai envie de voir ce qu'ils sont quoi
j'ai envie de dire aux Français vous
allez voir j'ai tellement bien
Nicolas Sarkozy avec le FNPS finalement
de dire que on préfère dire qu'on vote
blanc et que le FN finalement ressemble
un peu au PS on choisit pas entre les
deux c'est d'éviter que nous apparitions
comme les les la connivence pour le coup
là c'est l'expression de Marine Le Pen
c'est l'UMPS voilà le MPS voilà on est
ensemble finalement on est dans le même
marigot et vous pouvez pas dire tous les
matins les socialistes sont en train de
mettre le pays au fond du trou et dans
le même temps dire j'appelle à voter
socialiste quand il s'agit de
départementale pour la Présidentielle
votre choix est déjà fait si si ça se
peut vous avez déjà vu comme vous êtes
un homme intelligent que vous avez
l'oeil vif
et que vous êtes en plus journaliste à
l'AFP grand agence
vous avez toutes les qualités vous avez
raison
vous avez lu le programme des Front
national
les pays s'effondre un deux mois mais
alors j'ai pas envie que mon pays soit
dans le trou et dans le gouffre
en cas de victoire annoncée aux
élections départementales
il dit que la France aura la gueule de
bois avec des scores très élevés le FN
défigurait l'image républicaine de notre
pays nordique les Français vous pensez
que dans l'image républicaine du pays
parce que vous pensez que au Pays-Bas
tous les observateurs européens de la
vie politique française n'ont pas déjà
constaté que le Front national était
aujourd'hui une formation politique qui
dépassait l'UMP et le Parti socialiste
ils ont eu besoin des départementales
sensibilité
de de passion ou de tentation à l'égard
du Front national tout le monde le sait
voilà
je dis régulièrement que le Front
National est un parti national
qu'il est à la fois national sur ces
thèmes et socialiste sur ces thèmes
économiques donc je voilà je n'ai pas
chez Lady 10 fois et je continue à le
dire il est aussi collectiviste que
Mélenchon il est aussi démagogue que
peuvent l'être des parties populistes
donc vraiment j'ai aucun souci en la
matière sauf que pour des
départementales je ne veux pas que les
Français se disent finalement ils sont
dans la connivence et la complaisance
d'accord et donc je me fous s'il y en a
ça m'est égal qui est je regretterais
mais je considère qu'un département
n'est pas en cause on n'est pas en
danger ni la République en danger parce
qu'il y aura deux conseillers
départementaux dans une assemblée
départementale qui seront fournables
vous les avez au conseil régional déjà
vous avez senti que vous avez le
sentiment que la région
Haute-Normandie est tout d'un coup
défiguré parce qu'il y a des conseillers
régionaux Front national
des régionales vous allez emmener le
centre en Normandie ça c'est sûr que
c'est acté après il y a la question de
l'UMP on n'a pas très bien compris
est-ce qu'il vous soutiennent est-ce
qu'ils vont vous soutenir il y a eu un
une commission d'investiture il y a eu
deux femmes qui ont été désignées chef
de fil vous pourriez vous pourriez citer
leurs noms je ne m'en souviens pas
c'est pas très bien non ça c'est votre
job
et donc
simplement le
les choses sont extrêmement simples
Hervé Marseille le disait
l'état politique nous ne sommes plus
dans un système bipolaire nous sommes
dans un système tripolaire
dans un des modes électoraux qui se
restent bipolaire mais le système est
devenu tripolaire ce qui d'ailleurs
Jean-Marie Le Guen devrait en tirer les
conséquences devrait les amener à
modifier le mode de scrutin au
législative parce que le mode de scrutin
avec ce scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
favorise en fait la progression du Front
national à partir du moment où vous
arrivez à un certain niveau de score
bien je ferme la parenthèse
si nous sommes divisés centre
udi UMP
au premier tour des régionales nous
courons la catastrophe
si nous voulons gagner il nous faut que
nous il faut que nous soyons unis et
c'est assez simple donc moi mon message
était très clair il y a 13 régions et
très région dans lesquelles on doit être
ensemble
c'est aussi simple que c'est vous
préférez peut-être être devant en
Haute-Normandie
j'ai toujours porté l'idée de la
réunification deux jeudis la Normandie
c'est un boulot à temps plein
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas être
candidat aux régionales en décembre 2015
et dire en mars 2017 je vais être
candidat au législative
je dis que le celui qui va avoir en
charge de créer de construire la
Normandie certes on est sur nos bases
historiques mais il y a tout à
reconstruire la gouvernance
l'installation administrative les
politiques harmonisés puisqu'elles sont
très différentes entre la haute et la
Basse-Normandie pourtant toutes les deux
socialistes
construire engagé réorganiser tout cela
je les fais quand j'ai été ministre de
la Défense pour restructurer les armées
je sais à quel point il faut créer de
l'enthousiasme il faut de l'écoute de
l'attention de la pédagogie et que c'est
un boulot à temps plein ça veut dire
vous démissionneriez ça veut dire que je
ne serai plus parlementaire si j'étais
président de la région Normandie ça ça
fait pas de doute parce que pour début
2016 c'est pour moi un boulot à temps
plein vous ne pouvez pas être dans un
dans un job comme celui-ci est considéré
que soit vous continuez à exercer
d'autres fonctions politiques soit de
dire j'y suis pour 15 mois et dans
l'hypothèse où les choses vont bien soit
je vais revenir au gouvernement soit
je vais revenir au Parlement donc pas de
gouvernement non plus si vous étiez élu
président de région vous imaginez vous
avez la responsabilité de reconstruire
une région de lui donner une politique
d'essayer d'être innovant de créer une
gouvernance que je voudrais en réseau et
non pas centralisé dans un même point
vous avez des dizaines d'administrations
auxquelles vous avez été obligé il y a
deux directement impliquent un sol il y
a 10 agences en charge ça on va en faire
qu'une on va essayer de rationaliser
tout ça et de dire je commence le boulot
de 15 mois excusez-moi mais on m'appelle
pour éventuellement rentrer dans un
gouvernement je pense que ces temps-là
sont terminés voilà c'est clair le sujet
dont on va beaucoup parler vous en avez
déjà parlé vous dites que la droite
l'UMP lui dit doit être uni en tout cas
pour les pour les régionales citer
Laurent Wauquiez pas du tout non
on pourra en parler après si vous voulez
mais non non il va y avoir un problème
d'alliance avec Laurent Wauquiez
certains de vos amis oui alors
comme je voyais savoir je dis que on
peut pas avoir un système à la carte et
que si on décide de considérer Laurent
Wauquiez comme inacceptable pour
comme le fait Jean-Christophe Lagarde le
président de lui dire il fait en même
temps les parlementaires pour les
anciennes de la région considère que
c'est compatible donc leur expliquer les
choses mais je dis qu'il y a une chose
on peut pas il peut pas être
incompatible au premier tour et
compatible au deuxième tour soit il est
complètement incompatible et ça il est
incompatible sur les deux tours mais
dans ce cas-là il va falloir faire le
tri si je puis dire parce que le
discours de Laurent Wauquiez en effet à
la droite de l'UMP il y en a d'autres
dans d'autres régions donc ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir avoir une équation qui
va être extrêmement compliquée à moins
de considérer que l'UDI estime que le
discours de l'UMP devient trop droitier
et qu'il faut changer d'alliance mais il
faut que les choses soient dites et
faites c'est très région très pour vous
à moins autant que possible j'ai vu
qu'en Île-de-France on préférait
éventuellement avoir un système mais si
c'est un accord qui
amène Valérie Pécresse considéré que le
centre de t'avoir son expression en
Île-de-France et que le MP doit l'avoir
très bien c'est voilà moi je suis en
train de ces histoires mais je dis que
dans nombre de régions
où le Front National
et virera en tête au soir du premier
tour au risque de virer en tête soit de
premier tour l'Union d'abord l'Union
d'accord doit être là et donc l'Union
doit se continuer en 2017 il va y avoir
une primaire de la droite et du centre
ben ça fera partie des débats que nous
aurons parce que
je dis que il y a pour nous
deux éléments qu'il faut avoir en ligne
de compte la première c'est éviter de
que nous soyons les facteurs de 2002 si
je puis dire ni
Chevènement ni Christiane toubira
deuxième question donc est-ce que
deuxième question pardon je termine et
la deuxième question c'est est-ce que
nous avons un candidat crédible à
l'élection présidentielle
pour l'instant non ça fait c'est une
évidence Jean-Christophe Lagarde lui
souhaite qu'il y a un candidat centriste
j'ai payé pour ça donc je peux le dire
pas de nouveau monsieur 1% je vous
remercie de me rappeler ça la
présidentielle
la présidentielle
c'est
une histoire
dans laquelle il faut rentrer dans
l'inconscient collectif du pays c'est
une sédimentation extrêmement longue
compte tenu du caractère monarchiste de
nos institutions
d'une part d'autre part alors Hollande
vous allez me dire l'exception mais il
est rentré dans un il a eu un calendrier
astral absolument incroyable sans
l'accident de New York il ne serait
jamais là
si vous regardez les parcours ce sont
des parcours de personnes qui ont des
responsabilités politiques majeures
pendant des années
ces schéma-là je pense que
malheureusement pour ceux qui voudraient
d'ores et déjà être en direction
présidentielle il n'a pas encore bougé
une question encore est-ce que Nicolas
Sarkozy doit cesser de toujours dire que
c'est François Bayrou qui est le
responsable de sa défaite en 2012 selon
vous bah c'est clair que François Bayrou
que l'électorat n'a pas oublié cette
histoire-là ça ça fait absolument qu'il
y a doute deuxièmement les sondeurs
disent que ça n'est pas le cas ça n'est
pas le cas donc Nicolas Sarkozy doit
arrêter de toujours souvent
mais mais moi je j'écoute les grands
instituts de sondage qui ont toujours
expliqué que ça n'aurait pas modifié le
résultat du compte merci Guillaume
pierre internaute maintenant on va vous
interroger comme ancien ministre de la
Défense bien sûr même si vous voulez pas
revenir au gouverne dans un gouvernement
éventuel on l'a compris quand vous serez
vous voulez rêver président de région
je dis que je la région est une assuji
ah non je parle pas je parle pas du
reste je dis que la région c'est une
question qui reste encore ouverte quand
la candidature pas une chose encore
aujourd'hui inscrite
on a une interrogation sur le centre
encore qu'incarne-t-il donc de
spécifique dans le domaine des idées
puisque vous avez énuméré au début de
cette émission vos idées forces qu'on
retrouve en fait un peu à l'UMP sur le
réforme libérale alors que reste-t-il
dans le domaine des idées au centre
est-ce que c'est ce que Louis Sibille a
tenté de savoir l'Afrique en lumière
c'est le nouveau combat de Jean-Louis
Borloo carte à l'appui mais en quittant
la politique il l'a plongé son parti
dans l'obscurité d'autant plus qu'au
centre il y a plusieurs camps Morin par
exemple vient clairement de la famille
libérale
la garde vient clairement de la famille
démocrate chrétienne et Borlo venait de
la famille radicale donc d'un
libéralisme de gauche et tout ça
c'est très très compatible en termes
gouvernemental mais sa vie difficilement
en termes partisans s'il y a quelques
différences idéologiques l'ADN commun
des centriste c'est l'Europe dans le
système européen les centristes sont
comme des poissons dans l'eau parce que
c'est un système qui correspond à ce
qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne les
oblige pas à choisir entre la droite et
la gauche mais qui leur permet de
participer à une aventure collective
avec la droite et la gauche le problème
du centre c'est qu'il est tiraillé entre
la droite et la gauche pour conquérir
son indépendance François Bayrou avait
un ton voulu créer une troisième voie
sur les municipales il y a il y a eu des
le modem c'est carrément éclaté et puis
maintenant il est en train de rentrer
dans le rond parce que le MoDem a
compris même si François Bayrou ne
l'avoue pas directement que le fait
d'allier de n'être ni de droite ni de
gauche puisqu'il a quitté la droite et
qu'il a été rejeté par la gauche c'était
avec le mode de scrutin actuel
proprement suicidaire aujourd'hui le
centre compte 74 parlementaires et il
est à la tête d'une centaine de villes
de plus de 10 000 habitants
voilà Perrine nous a rejoint donc votre
ADN l'Europe on l'a compris ça pourrait
je suis pas débouché sur un changement
d'alliance du côté de la gauche certains
plaids en ce sens même Alain Juppé il
parle d'une nouvelle grande famille
centrale famille
je pense que nous sommes les seuls à
porter réellement l'idée d'une Europe
intégrée fédérale c'est clair encore
voilà mais après quelle alternative vous
représenter exactement par rapport à
l'UMP est-ce que les électeurs s'y
retrouvent finalement parce quand on
voit par exemple ici au Sénat finalement
le groupe udi le groupe UMP il va de la
même chose vous croyez
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'une je suis un
vrai libéral pour ma part
comme beaucoup du MP bon
je suis un vrai européen
troisièmement je suis fondamentalement
attaché à l'idée
à la protection des libertés
individuelles c'est je déteste
l'idée que de troquer la liberté contre
la sécurité
on verra en même temps il y a des
contraintes qui parfois obligent mais je
vous rappelle que quand j'étais au
gouvernement je suis celui qui a émis
des doutes sur des fichiers et qu'on
appelait les fichiers de vie j'ai fait
renoncer quand j'ai vu que je ne l'ai
pas entendu au sein du gouvernement et
puis et puis aussi nous sommes
profondément attachés à une autre
lecture qui est une de l'action
politique en considérant qu'une partie
de la transformation du pays ne vient
pas du sommet d'un système totalement
centralisé qui est aujourd'hui
totalement impuissant mais au contraire
des territoires et de d'une capacité de
d'élan qui part de la base et justement
sur les territoires avant de parler de
des armées et de la défense est-ce que
sur la réforme territoriale vous avez
l'impression que François Hollande c'est
un peu casser les dents finalement sur
la réforme du millefeuille territorial
tout à l'heure en clair le le lobby et
la puissance du lobby local est-elle du
département
comportementaliste mais c'est valable
pour tout il y a des questions qui
pourtant devraient être au cœur du sujet
à quoi sert aujourd'hui d'avoir 36000
communes quand vous avez des communes
qu'on peut Aaron
qui ont transféré la quasi totalité de
leurs compétences aux intercommunalités
la question de la place des départements
est bien entendu devrait être vu de
façon différente en fonction de de dans
les départements ruraux comme le mien au
semis ruraux il faut qu'une il faut une
institution intermédiaire dans d'autres
on voit bien que ça n'a plus de sens
bref il y a il y a eu une tentative de
rationalisation et en fait sur les
compétences par exemple on a continué à
enfiler des systèmes total opaque
affreux à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
une une reculade absolue sur le sujet
sur les armées
Mées comptez aujourd'hui à une quand
même exceptionnelles à la fois sur le
plan intérieur avec le plan Vigipirate
renforcé et puis sur les opérations
extérieures selon le journal Le Monde ce
soir François Hollande pourrait arbitrer
pour épargner près de 18500 emplois dans
la défense est-ce que ça vous semble
plausibles en l'état actuel des déficits
publics la France parce que j'ai dit
qu'il fallait au moins 20 000 militaires
de plus mais voilà
est-ce que ça vous en faisable on est
actuellement
il est une chose est claire l'engagement
de l'armée française telle qu'il est
aujourd'hui
ne permet pas les réductions d'effectif
qui avait été prévues si vous
n'augmentez
depuis janvier
ce qui est clair c'est que les
réductions d'effectifs qui étaient
prévues dans la nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire puisqu'il était
prévu entre 20 et 30 000 de plus
cela il faut pas les faire
comment on finance à ce moment-là le
budget de les armées voilà mais c'est
pas simplement des postes après il faut
les équiper il faut l'entraînement c'est
pas c'est pas uniquement cela mais
il faut avoir une chose simple c'est que
quand vous avez un soldat quelque part
ça veut dire qu'il y en a trois
il y a le retour à la maison si je puis
dire bon retour pour la formation donc
si vous maintenez 7000 hommes
pour protéger les Français dans le cadre
de Vigipirate ça veut dire qu'il en faut
20 000
si vous aviez pas le choix il a pas le
choix
c'est que vous en avez tellement des
gens en opération extérieure que quand
vous quand vous mettez l'ensemble de
l'équation vous voyez bien que si vous
continuez à si vous ne cessez pas la
réduction des effectifs de l'armée de
terre l'armée terre est incapable de
remplir ses missions alors plus de
moyens pour le budget des abonnés il
manque déjà de milliards
300 millions alors il faut qu'on a du
mal à trouver il est aujourd'hui un peu
supérieur à 30 milliards d'euros
il y a deux choses à faire
la première c'est de repenser notre
modèle d'armée nous ne sommes plus une
puissance militaire globale ça c'est à
long terme parce que
la puissance d'accord
et la puissance militaire globale
c'était de dire en fait nous sommes
nationales nous sommes capables d'entrer
en premier nous pouvons faire des
opérations massives sol c'est pas vrai
nous ne pouvons le faire seul
on Iraq il nous faut des ravitailleurs
américains
on n'a pas été seul et quand on a fait
l'opération par exemple en Libye avec
les Britanniques heureusement que la
défense est entier que que la guerre
électronique etc c'était des moyens qui
nous étaient donnés par d'autres bien
donc je dis il faut créer un corps
expéditionnaire de 10000 hommes
capable en effet de faire en autonomie
stratégique c'est à dire en totale
indépendance une opération militaire
type Mali et que sur le reste nous
disions on a des trous capacitaires
qu'on assume et qui fait que comme nous
intervenons tout le temps ensuite en
coalition et bien on apportera un
certain nombre de capacités militaires
c'est ce que font tous les Européens et
bien deuxième sujet il fait exactement
le contraire mais je vous le dis le
prochain Président de la République sera
obligé de le faire c'est le nucléaire
vous avez aujourd'hui des crédits
d'équipements qui représentent entre 20
et 25% pour le nucléaire compte tenu de
la de la nouvelle génération des
sous-marins nucléaires lançant dans le
genre et compte tenu de la rénovation de
la composante aérienne on va
aboutir un nucléaire qui va représenter
40% des crédits alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on abandonne
c'est-à-dire la composante une
proposition sacrilège dans notre pays ah
oui parce que le nucléaire c'est tabou
il y a tellement de nucléocrates dans
notre pays que dans les parties aussi
j'entends bien mais je je le dis
voilà je dis que ça n'est pas tenable la
France c'est pas la Corée du Nord nous
avons besoin d'une armée conventionnelle
opérationnelle équipée ayant des moins
de transport et en des moyens aéroportés
bref
tout ce dont nous souffrons aujourd'hui
dans nos opérations parce que faute de
moyens nouveau on attend les
hélicoptères
à la
il y a pas d'autres choix c'est écrit
c'est écrit et je vous rappelle écrire
dans le dernier discours du chef de
l'État qui est réaffirmé la dissuasion
nucléaire française avec ces deux
composants
de dire ce qui va se passer
je vous rappelle que d'autres présidents
de la République ont fait des choix sur
le nucléaire qui à l'époque ont été
vécues comme des sacrilèges François
Mitterrand Jacques Chirac tout à fait
dans les deux cas de figure est-ce que
la France s'en est plus mal porté en
termes de sécurité et de protection
est-ce que je peux ajouter un point
supplémentaire sur nucléaire
moi j'aimerais que les Européens
portent l'idée sans naïveté de l'abandon
de l'arme nucléaire sur la planète
je la prolifération est une menace
considérable pour la planète pour les
terriens et on va être dans une équation
progressivement qui est une équation
impossible au fur et à mesure que des
pays accèdent des niveaux de richesse et
de technologie comparable aux autres ou
supérieur le discours qui est le nôtre
qui est de dire nous pour notre
indépendance et notre sécurité on a
besoin de cette arme qui est l'arme
nucléaire mais vous vous n'en avez pas
besoin pour votre sécurité ça ne sera
pas tenable et donc la prolifération
finira par envahir le monde et si on
veut éviter qu'un jour nous allions dans
quelques décennies vers un hiver
nucléaire je dis que il serait bon que
les Européens portent ce magnifique
combat en demandant aux Américains et
aux Russes de faire l'essentiel de
l'effort bien entendu ce naïf mais
pourquoi voudriez-vous que ce soit naïf
enfin c'est drôle voilà on a pas le
droit d'avoir de belles ambitions c'est
une belle ambition bon pour les autres
c'est difficile pour nous déjà on a du
mal non mais c'est pas nous de le faire
le premier mais c'est d'abord mais
attendez les Russes et les Américains
c'est 95% de de l'ensemble de l'arsenal
nucléaire
en attendant on va faire l'économie
d'une nouvelle intervention en Libye
selon vous
écoutez je suis comme vous une
plateforme du terrorisme nous sommes
d'accord je suis comme vous ça
m'inquiète beaucoup
et
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
chaque intervention militaire se sont
des interventions on est dans
l'endiguement
mais en aucun cas dans la construction
d'une d'un projet politique
quelque sorte il y a pas les buts de
guerre pour l'instant on stoppe daesh on
évite le pire je pense en Irak mais en
même temps la gangrène gagne et donc il
y a là une équation extrêmement
compliquée j'ai pas la réponse immédiate
mais ce que je sais c'est que il y a de
quoi être inquiet on a parlé du
remaniement éventuel après les élections
départementales tout à l'heure François
Hollande aurait demandé à Jean-Yves
Driant qui est tenté par les élections
régionales
en Bretagne de rester avec vous dites
oui il faut qu'il reste un bon ministre
ah oui il fait son boulot c'est pas de
problème
il fait son boulot il y a pas de
problème non je joue
de simple c'est que Le Drian et voilà un
bon ministre a fait le boulot
merci monsieur me remercier Perrine
merci Michel bonsoir à tous et à très
vite